[Music]
do you want to do
a little bit more of that mark harley or
you want to do a little bit of
stuttering john
you know
i we haven't checked in with old stutter
and john in a while
okay stuttering john it is stuttering
john had a guest on his show i will let
him introduce the guest
nikki freed how are you sweet
and in that moment
and in that moment yeah
nicki free
just absolutely sealed her loss
right like that it's
not that being on john's show is gonna
hurt her but it's just like
she's now got the stuttering john stink
on her like it's like a it's like a it's
a supernatural thing it's not you know
what i mean before you know it you'll be
borrowing your neighbor's wi-fi
no no nikki
let's hear it so i figured we watch a
little bit of this what do you think
hello sir so good to see you all right
can we get to santa's then
yeah you know what hey ronnie d hear me
out here
come on we've been more than kind to you
bro
get come on man fi give us five five
minute interview have a five minute
interview
so good to see you too and i'm so happy
to have you on again me too i we had
such a fun conversation last time
i know and
god nikki we need wait
she's a repeat guest on the stuttering
john show
oh has she seen his numbers
have you seen her numbers
okay all right that good you know when
you put it like that
very good
coming up next we're going to have
charlie
crist
charlie chris has actually been a
governor he wouldn't go on this [ __ ]
show
anyway you have to wait every day
charlie chris wakes up and decides what
party he's in
gonna win that's true charlie chris has
switched from baby face to heel more
times than the big show yeah [ __ ]
seriously
no things things are are just insane not
just of florida but the entire country i
feel like every time i talk to somebody
there's just tension like everybody is
feeling the tension and merce i'm sorry
i don't mean to keep pausing people get
mad because but he cannot believe
that a serious
i serious
potential gubernatorial cabinet of the
state of florida
is on stuttering john's podcast
nicki free
it's uh
it's only getting exacerbated by the
world i like the fact that she's like oh
my god the tensions and everything's so
crazy in florida yeah not anywhere i go
yeah i'm fine over here too yeah
traffic
pretty much people are getting along
yeah the traffic there's a lot of
traffic yeah that sucks but the way
she's like yeah you know everything's
been crazy here in florida no you're
right a [ __ ] super bowl couple world
series a few stanley cups [ __ ]
business is open we're all making you
know it's been crazy yeah don't make
merchandise back on our fictional
speedboats
seriously
but how it like because you live in
florida obviously
how is it to be there and then every day
see ron desantis do something more
egregious it's just like
it's like i don't know stuttering john
how did it feel like to work for howard
stern and see your boss every day do
something more egregious to mentally
handicap people how about that john
huh
not that i care i think it's funny but
i'm also not on my [ __ ] high horse
remember when he was rolling around in
the ashes of a dead fan that was funny
yeah i remember that that's who nicki
fried is talking to
just when you think he's gotten low
enough he goes another step lower i wish
i knew if this was live i would have
loved to be in that chat
john john talks
like
john bullshits about like you know
politics and all these things he doesn't
know anything about but you notice how
he has this habit of like
saying stuff without ever saying stuff
like he's just basically like he didn't
cite a single thing that he hates about
the sanctions
just every time he does something low he
goes lower he can't talk he doesn't know
details no points of reference
right he cites nothing
he really does sound like a gta npc like
really
he sounds like he sounds like
if i knew nothing about politics right
and i went to a bar and i was like one
of those guys that knows nothing about
politics don't follow it don't care and
some chick at a bar that i want to [ __ ]
starts bashing around desantis and i'm
like half listening right it feels like
that where like i'd go i don't know
anything about what she's talking about
but i kind of want to [ __ ] this checks
and she's like yeah like what do you
think about desantis i feel man it's
like you know just when he goes lower
you think he can't go any lower he goes
you know you know what's so funny i mean
you know it's it's [ __ ] it's
egregious frankly you know it's so you
know what's so funny i know you're not
caught up with better calls all the
season and i won't spoil anything but
there's a little a small scene where
saul's trying to gain somebody's
confidence
and they're into sports like really into
sports like a local sports team and saw
doesn't know [ __ ] about sports right so
he goes into that would you describe
exactly what happened because hey man
what do you think about ohio state like
can you believe they recorded so-and-so
and saul goodman was doing like yeah
that's crazy i know right wow what a
powerhouse that guy is knowing nothing
about it and he [ __ ] his way to the
entire conversation
i mean there's some things you just
[ __ ] your way through
that's what this feels like though you
just know nothing you're like yeah it's
just egregious you know it's like it
goes low enough and it just keeps going
lower
how does that feel for you it's it's
frustrating you know it is so
frustrating and we're in such a scary
time you know and i don't think that
most people outside of florida know
what's happening when it comes to to
this one issue
we just have an appointment last week of
a new secretary of state
okay new secretary of state the one
who's supposed to be overseeing our
secure elections
and he's a known q anon
so
i'm sorry are you saying people that do
that are not allowed to hold political
office
ma'am
because i would also argue the
department of agriculture should have
controlled the concealed and carry
permits either but here we are the
funniest thing is is that
and every time somebody goes to pump gas
in florida and marsh you know this
there's a sticker of the department of
agriculture person and that's nikki
freed so every time somebody was pissed
at the gas station without them knowing
it they subconsciously started hating
nikki freed because their face is on
every pump
yeah nikki you're not doing great with
that plus anybody that's tried to uh get
a concealed carry this last two years
and trust me it's been a lot of people
um they don't like you either because
their [ __ ] took way longer than it
should have it was supposed to take
um yeah nicki freed's office uh the
department of agriculture like we're all
[ __ ] up in florida right so we have
the department of agriculture and at
some point they just merged the like two
offices and they're like look the people
that do the gun permits are just gonna
do it through because they basically
like looked at it budget wise and went
like there's no reason we need two
different offices for this like you
[ __ ] agriculture [ __ ] really
aren't doing enough work anyway so we're
just gonna run all this through your
office and that's the thing like the
reason nikki freed is in the department
of agriculture because it's one of those
things nobody cares about yeah so they
don't really like nobody's really
contesting that office
so that's how she got it nobody really
cares about the department of
agriculture
uh nobody really cares about stuttering
john so they have a lot in common but
yeah like you were saying too the
department of agriculture in florida is
in charge of gun licenses
agriculture and the gas for some reason
it's super weird here but
um what's even weirder is that she's
doing stuttering john's show
to the services that they get locally
and then to have
a party
that has people like desantis
and um say trump say trump say trump say
trump say trump please say trump or rand
paul
greene you know what i'm paul burton all
attacking
the lgbtq plus community hey you know
the one thing the stuttering jar always
was about when he was doing stern was he
respected the lgbtq community
is that so do you know that a cursory
youtube search would show otherwise i'm
already looking john
do you know how easy it would be to
disprove that you phony hack
i'm sure you watch
just a stuttering john howard stern
super clip you'll find plenty of yeah no
there is that's right john or did you
you try to take those down from the
internet mr lgbtq friendly
stuttering this this [ __ ] prick is
trying to pretend
now that he's lgbtq plus friendly
you know what this is merch this is
somebody john is trying to attach
himself to something like with like but
he doesn't understand it like you were
saying earlier he doesn't understand
politics but he's trying to so he goes
okay so
he looks up online what dude ike would
love to see his google search history
what do democrats take
okay they're forum
perfect like don't worry nikki i'm four
to
two exactly
what they're doing to the
is just egregious by the way use that
word yet today by the way taper good
luck good luck bleeping those out
because we're clipping this
it's
it's really it's really unbelievable
it's atrocious it's atrocious and i tell
this story all the time my my step
brother came out to me when we were in
high school and so this has been you
know this is family um this is something
that i have been and i remember having a
fight guys nicki freed has a monopoly on
living in florida and having gay family
members yes she's the only one that's
ever had the only one it's very personal
to her
my ap
physics class my senior year of and this
is uh of high school this is exactly
when uh don't ask don't tell had come
out yeah and there was a whole big
debate of that and i so i remember being
in the trenches back in high school on
this issue and and so i see what they've
been doing um and look at the end of the
day
they're going after everybody if you
they're going after the black community
you just heard me talk about the
congressional map hey
why don't we do a super cut of how many
times stuttering john said the n-word
again
i would say a cursory youtube search but
it's probably
kicked off of youtube for violating in
terms of service
it's in all the voter suppression bills
they're going after the gay community
now you know they want women back into
the home and out of the workforce yes
yes i think women want to do that too
though
um it's every single you know community
and and unfortunately as a member of the
jewish community
what
and there it is
well no clearly no no no no she's on to
something i don't want to be unfair here
because if there's one thing that the
san francisco one thing desantis has
been [ __ ] really like tone-deaf about
i mean one group of people he's really
left out
has been jewish people
this is insanity to me man
that's like the one thing about desantis
that i don't like is how much he grovels
did you explain yeah i don't like that
too much either
but you can't call him anti-semitic i
know that's ridiculous
we're seeing the rise of anti-semitism
in our state we're seeing
where
uh a couple of gdl flyers oh okay
protest with nazi flags
oh there she's trying to do the whole
thing of those [ __ ] real nazis that
showed up out of the tpusa thing
remember those ah real nazis
i remember that show that came on after
clarissa yeah
they came after
clarissa explains her tattoo
candidates across the entire country um
that are running for office it is not
easy out here but there's a lot of
really good people um that are trying to
step up that are trying
yeah okay john what do you have to say
about that you know behemoth of a
company i mean that's that's just plain
stupid yeah the desantis going after
disney's what he's talking about that's
just stupid desantis stripping disney of
its own special imperial county district
where they were the law and they were
also emerging of that literally
that the literal definition of fascism
right
is a merging between corporations and
the government to create like you know a
big authoritarian group
wouldn't that have been the definition
of ready creek yeah exactly yep it's
it's fascism it's literally
a business it wasn't a government the
government entity and it was a monarchy
ready creek was basically a monarchy
well it was yeah it was like basically a
special economic district yeah but then
that automatically makes you now
government too like if the government
said to me
if the government said to you and me you
know what rotc media we're going to give
you um a little piece of polk county
that's now going to be your own special
you guys own it you're in charge of the
government of it right like we're a
government now like if we're the one
picking firefighters and policemen we'll
have sausage castle too the second
location will be in our little area or
we just get them to move the the og one
that's true we'll be like look bro we
will give you protections that you just
cannot even dream of up in lake county
yep no drugs are criminalized here
all the cops all the cops in our
district have to dye their hair like
mike busey exactly like the frosted top
crazy guys
of cops our cop is mike busey yeah
yes no he's the sheriff but then he gets
to pick his deputies exactly
i like it and they're all just [ __ ]
florida weirdos that he just dribbled
down from the dregs of florida
and we'll have mayor fred durst it'll be
amazing yeah this is my boy i'm
deputizing him this is deputy kai he's
from daytona beach i've met him a while
i met him a couple years ago man
he used to sell molly but he doesn't
sell it anymore i mean he could still he
still gets me molly though
look look john here's the thing if a
company is doing bad like if a company
is legitimately doing bad is a bad
corporation not doing good by its
employees bad customer service no matter
how big they disney does terrible their
employees talk to any former employee
they [ __ ] hate working there they
basically call it slavery indentured
servitude ask the people here's a fun
little fact that a lot of people that
don't live here don't know you ever been
to epcot probably if you've ever come
here if you go to epcot they have all
the different lands around the world and
the one thing about those lands around
the world is number one this disney
doesn't own those those things they're
funded by the department of tourism from
their home countries so like the
japanese pavilion is funded by japanese
department of tourism because you know
the whole point is for you to go there
and you get a piece of their culture
maybe you'll visit so the people that
work at those lands are from those
countries everybody that works the japan
pavilion is japanese everybody that
works
at the um everyone that works at the um
you know the french pavilion is french
that's pretty racist right everyone that
works at the italian pavilion is a
rapist so
they
you know but but my point is they're
they're like damn it that was funny yeah
they're all from they're all from the
cut
they're off in their country but it's a
thing you know where those people those
people are technically considered
interns
they live in a [ __ ] apartment complex
that disneyland i don't know about you
i've told you about the accomplishments
they have they have to be in bed they
have to be in bed by 11 p.m to when they
come in like these are adults by the way
like 22 23 years or college kids
normally
and
you're not allowed to bring any guests
in so you can't even like you know bring
a chick to bed we can't do that then
they have a bus system now disney's bus
system for for people for for paying
customers is really good very efficient
however they don't use that bus system
for those employees they use a
third-party thing called transtar which
if you've ever seen them are the ones
that are like black from the soot and
like just falling apart
and they're always late plus like the
bus they had to take in major league
yeah remember when they started cutting
their budget and they're always late so
then the kids always say like i'm not
even making money because i have to
spend like 20 on uber to get to work
because if you're late they dock you and
they treat them like slaves they pay
them basically minimum wage to stand out
of the sun 14 hours a day and they drug
test them on top of all that
what a lovely company no but you're
right disney does really well by their
employees
a big you know big corporation yes but
that's not disney
it's not disney um let's talk about no
this is a really good corporation they
don't do anything wrong what the [ __ ]
man this is insane right this is insane
this is [ __ ] also i love i love this
this is a great interview and i'm loving
this because i can see that she's just
as much of a [ __ ] as john yeah also
can't make a good point
by the way again but like you pointed
out at the beginning merch there was
nothing to gain by going on stuttering
john's show except make yourself look
stupider
i mean and by the way
congratulations you're doing it
i don't know how but you're doing it
disney good ron desantis bad hey by the
way can i ask you something
royce yeah since we've uh stripped them
of ready creek and uh all this stuff's
gone on yeah
what happened did anything happen did
disney leave no disney's still here
they're actually
did they cut jobs no actually they just
hired like two thousand more people
did they did they so they're not like
planning on maybe moving to another
state they're not gonna start taking
apart the uh the probably trillion
dollar
of disney compound that they've built
over [ __ ] 50 years they're not going
to just dismantle that and move i'm
gonna say no only because i think they
just started building a new roller
coaster well then i guess nothing bad
happened nikki except they're gonna have
to pay their fair share yeah get their
own police force anymore ooh
sorry nikki
a firearm
and and so we saw as a commissioner of
agriculture i oversee uh gun licensing
in the states so cons here you go merch
weapons security guards any of your
other special specialization licenses is
run by the department of agriculture and
saw that there was an opportunity to
show a nexus
um to say look look how crazy these laws
are that somebody who is addicted to
alcohol or somebody who's addicted to
opioids can go purchase a gun but
somebody who is a lawful marijuana user
cannot pause
pause
pause
pause
i did
no you can't you stupid [ __ ]
as somebody who's in charge of
overseeing licensing for firearms you of
all people should know
that uh question 11a on the atf form
specifically asks
if you are
uh currently addicted to or have you
know especially like if you have a
record for being like on the record
addicted to
all of these things and if you have uh
it says if you've developed a dependency
on any of the following things
you're not supposed to get this gun so
no
no nikki it's it's actually
across the board there's there's still
protections for opiate users and drunks
uh uh versus potheads right
like there's not it asks
all of them
i hate this woman and so what's
happening is that cannabis users are
either one because it's the atf form so
i may make sure people understand the
atf form that makes it you mean the one
that mercer specifically told you what
number it was and what it said very
specific asking is a specific question
um about your usage of
a federally illegal controlled substance
and they've added additional language
over the years that say even if your
state has legalized
or has a medical program it's still
considered federally illegal and you
have to say yes to this question which
was dead
[ __ ] just [ __ ] contradicted herself
in the same [ __ ] breath
she just said that the [ __ ] line in
the [ __ ] atf forum says any federally
illegal substance
what the f i
yeah i know she's terrible right
skip ahead a little bit i will agree
that it is [ __ ] stupid i agree with
that yeah like but she's not the only
one saying that i mean i think desantis
um
would agree that it's stupid but we're
we're a state we're not the feds we
can't make you know what i mean yeah
that's something that you'd have to
you'd have to push but the democrats
don't push it because they always want
to dangle it like oh man at this time
we'll give it to you so they always want
to have something to run yeah you know
that's a really good point your
arguments with the atf
right your argument isn't with florida
it's not even with desantis your
arguments with the atf you don't even
need to change the law and go oh it's
federally legal all you have to do is
have somebody in the office of the atf
change it and go you know look that's it
yeah we're just gonna leave weed off of
this thing
the uh so getting back it was so uh
because i know you've been very you're
okay john
you're so into the pro-choice thing and
and
i just can't believe they're taking
because
you know the reproductive
jesus christ stuttering john really is
the final evolution of brendan schaub
huh
jesus christ a reproductive rights away
from women i don't know she's right how
a woman could actually vote
for any republican at this point because
i know you do because some women believe
in the sanctity of birth yeah because
you're a [ __ ] john that's yeah john
again you're just you're just saying
things that you think
they want to hear right but you're not
saying anything of substance i don't
know i don't know how any woman could
hey john let me ask you something
men shouldn't really like tell women
what to do we shouldn't mansplain and we
shouldn't um tell women what to do with
their bodies right you mean like howard
stern used to do
so why is he you men are allowed to talk
down to and and be shitty to women that
don't vote the way you do
like why is the left like they'll always
be like oh these republicans want to
destroy women and blacks and blah blah
blah but as soon as a woman or a black
person steps out of line they're
screaming and calling clarence thomas
the n-word immediately immediately and
then you have a guy telling a woman i
don't know how you could do that how
could you
vote for a republican you shouldn't be
doing that if you're a woman and it's
like so you're
are you mansplaining and telling me how
to vote as a man but that's a really
good point to go i can't believe
no because like here's the thing i can't
believe why somebody has their beliefs
that i don't agree with i don't agree
with them that's okay but i believe that
people can think differently than me i
jo i can't believe the women
what are you doing man yeah homie this
you've been
this is florida desantis is gonna pull
in a lot of numbers with these broads
yeah you don't even know
debating in pro-choice
pro-choice rallies across the state yep
i don't either
he
you know what you know what [ __ ]
stuttering fraud did
he he's reading
he googled headlines about desantis and
bad or whatever
and now he's reading the article titles
as questions to her that's i want you to
hear this
that's what the last thing that he just
said was basically tell me if i'm wrong
the title of an article watch watch
watch watch the pro choice rallies
across the state yep oh so i didn't go
far back enough hold on sorry uh here
look
republican at this point because i know
you do you've been participating in
pro-choice
pro-choice rallies across the state see
that was some reading you've been
participating
in pro-choice rallies across the state
because he did a google news search on
nicki free
and and probably had like three articles
come up and he figured they're all from
the orlando sentinel and one of them's
like nikki freed uh goes on a blitz are
you sure you don't no choice appearances
sure you don't mean nikki cox
through the old bob saga joke so i
googled nicki freed and it came back
with why
yep
i don't either um i i don't either and
look
here here's the ending today nobody
wants more abortions let's also let's
what yeah
you guys do you [ __ ] liars guys
literally shout your abortions if you
take away the 15-week mandate which is
what she wants to do that means you want
there to be more abortions let's start
there that nobody wants that but given a
woman a right to choose a freedom we
like to talk about freedom here in the
state of florida the freedom to choose
what is best for herself and for her
family yeah she got 15 weeks i'm sorry
if 15 weeks not long enough that's
freedom your majesty that's three months
of freedom to decide
what you want to do
[ __ ] man
they twist the facts
and the stories that i hear all day long
from women from different past different
issues reasons why they've gotten
abortions um which is a personal
personal decision and you know not to go
into that libertarian line but like
you're running on a bunch of uh
anecdotal evidence that you got from
talking to people we don't know you even
really exist right no she talks to a
bunch of people that's why and i think i
have the clip here
[ __ ] i'm i i think i think i have the
clip that there was there was a there
was a uh
was there a big nikki friday rally there
was a presser where they could have the
press like it was a zoom presser but the
press could ask her any questions
and there was literally no no questions
and they had the awkwardly disconnect
let me see if i could find it uh i
should have pulled that one up sorry uh
oh i need to see that that's funny
[ __ ] i'm sure maybe someone will find it
faster than uh
than i will here while i look for it i
tell you what
why
don't we
why don't you tell people about
mybookie.a.g guysmybooky.ag
is a website that you can gamble on and
do all various sports betting type
things uh right now if you go to
mybookie.ag you can sign up use promo
code rtc and they're gonna give you uh
they're gonna match your first deposit
up to a g
and that's more money to gamble with of
course with all the fine sports that are
gonna be returning as the fall
approaches you know real sports like
football uh we all want to get in on
that racket
and uh yeah so get on over to mybook.ag
and hey in the meantime you know there's
other things you could bet on like
soccer or some [ __ ] i don't know look it
up my bookie.ag promo code rtc a matchup
first deposit uh up two thousand dollars
and you also got your castino games and
whatnot uh it's fun so go do it found it
nice
perfect timing actually
so uh this was a
this was a presser
and it was you know one of those virtual
pressers
uh with a couple of health experts uh at
the end uh she's asked to field any
questions
from uh the media so you ready here you
go
just to see how good how good she's
gonna do you wanna go ahead and wrap it
up
[Music]
you know who you know gets asked a lot
of questions
ron desantis that's a very good point